[Musique]
rien n'arrête l'offensive des talibans
en afghanistan et lee viennent de
prendre la ville de herat dans le même
temps ils se rapprochent de la capitale
kaboul après s'être emparés de la ville
stratégique de ghazni et des combats ont
lieu à kandahar l'essentiel de la moitié
nord du pays est désormais entre les
mains des insurgés le président avant
asseraf gagné s'est rendu dans la région
hier pour tenter de coordonner la
riposte
[Musique]
en algérie premier jour de deuil
national après la mort de soixante neuf
personnes liées aux feux de forêt dans
le nord du pays la kabylie est en proie
aux flammes depuis lundi à l'aide
internationale s'organise et des feux
liée aux fortes chaleurs mais la piste
criminelle est envisagée
[Musique]
en france confinement renforcée aux
antilles avec des indicateurs épidémique
qui explosent en guadeloupe les
commerces non essentiels les hôtels et
les plages fermées pour au moins trois
semaines comme en martinique où les
ministres de la santé et de l'outre-mer
sont en ce moment arrivé sur place pour
évaluer la situation nouvelle mesure
aussi en métropole avec un état des
lieux préoccupant selon le chef de
l'état
[Musique]
et
il est 20h bonsoir à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france et
on débute en afghanistan où les talibans
multiplient les prises ils se sont
emparés cet après-midi de la ville de
herat située à l ouest du pays dans le
même temps ils se rapprochent de la
capitale kaboul après avoir pris ghazni
les insurgés contrôlent désormais 11 des
34 capitale provinciale du pays et pour
tenter de coordonner la riposte le
président avoue ans s'est rendu hier
dans l'une des villes assiégées le récif
a ramé qui est robin pu l
l'avancée des talibans se poursuit
depuis la chute de ghazni ce jeudi matin
les insurgés ne sont plus qu'à 150 km de
kaboul au total sur les 34 provinces que
compte le pays près d'un tiers des
capitelles et aux mains des islamistes
notre priorité absolue reste la paix et
un dialogue pour un règlement négocié à
venir mais nous avons aussi un autre
travail pour défendre notre pays et le
peuple contre cette violence accrue des
talibans et d'autres groupes terroristes
il y à al qaïda et d'autres terroristes
internationaux qui combattent aux côtés
des talibans contre le peuple afghan et
le gouvernement c'est donc notre travail
de reprendre des territoires c'est aussi
le devoir et la responsabilité de nos
forces de défense et de sécurité
nationale et elle planifie cela
nd a traité une planification mise à mal
par la rapidité de l'offensive talibane
mais pas seulement au sein même de
l'armée afghanes de nombreux soldats en
détresse se sont rendus aux talibans et
les militaires ne sont pas les seuls à
fuir les combats à l'image du ministre
des finances réalité yanda qui a remis
sa démission avant de quitter le pays
aujourd'hui j'ai quitté mes fonctions de
ministre des finances par intérim dirigé
le ministère des finances a été le plus
grand honneur de ma vie mais il était
temps de me retirer pour m'occuper de
mes priorités personnelles j'ai confié à
monsieur halley mme chaïb brahimi
vice-ministre des recettes et des
douanes la responsabilité de ce poste
jusqu'à la nomination d'un nouveau
ministre depuis le départ des troupes
américaines entamé en mai dernier les
affrontements font rage entre insurgés
et forces gouvernementales
et les civils notamment femmes et
enfants sont les premières victimes de
ces batailles une situation humanitaire
est inquiétante qui n'a pas empêché les
états unis de confirmer le retrait de
ses troupes d'ici le 31 août prochain
au grand dam des afghans qui compte sur
la communauté internationale pour
engager un accord politique avec les
talibans
je pense que la communauté
internationale peut encore utiliser son
levier diplomatique
quand je dis cela je ne veux pas dire
qu'elle doit l'utiliser pour ses propres
relations publiques mais elle devrait
l'utiliser pour écouter le peuple afghan
par exemple si elle veut conclure un
accord avec les talibans ce qui est une
bonne chose car cela ouvre la voie à la
paix pourquoi n'at-elle pas inclus le
gouvernement et l'état afghan est conclu
un accord tripartite
car à ce stade nous sommes en train de
mettre en oeuvre ou nous avons mis en
oeuvre en tant qu'etat afghans des
choses que nous n'avons pas signé des
choses pour lesquelles nous ne sommes
pas engagés je pense donc qu'il est
nécessaire d'exercer un effet de levier
sur la base de ce que veut le peuple
afghan et d'utiliser le levier
diplomatique
en attendons les échanges diplomatiques
mène à l'impasse depuis mardi des
émissaires occidentaux sont à doha au
qatar dans le but de trouver un accord
de paix entre les deux parties sans
grand succès pour le moment et selon un
négociateur du gouvernement afghan à
kaboul a proposé aux talibans un accord
de partage du pouvoir en échange d'un
arrêt des violences la situation sur le
terrain est suivi de près par le
pentagone aux états unis alors que les
soldats américains auront quitté
l'afghanistan 3 août
nous nous concentrons sur la situation
de sécurité à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés actuellement qui encore une
fois nous l'avons reconnu se détériore
nous sommes certainement conscient des
progrès réalisés par les talibans en
termes de prise de contrôle d'un nombre
accru de capitale provinciale et notre
objectif est de soutenir les afghans sur
le terrain où et quand nous le pouvons
et d'achever ce retrait
je ne vais pas parler des éventualités
de planification des résultats
potentiels et l'autre chose que je
dirais c'est qu'aucune issue potentiels
ne doit être inévitable y compris la
chute de kaboul dans tout le monde
semble parler il ne doit pas en être
ainsi
et je pense que cela dépendra vraiment
du type de leadership politique et
militant hier que les afghans peuvent
rassembler pour renverser la vapeur ils
en ont la capacité lisent en ont la
capacité et maintenant il est vraiment
temps d'utiliser ces choses et les
talibans sont soutenues principalement
par le pakistan et l'arabie saoudite
comme nous l'expliquent pierre conesa
ancien haut fonctionnaire spécialiste
des questions stratégiques
internationales vous avez une contrainte
qui s'appelle la guerre globale contre
le terrorisme dans lequel des pays qui
peuvent être les plus dictatoriaux de la
planète sont considérées comme des
alliées ci prétend combattre le
terrorisme c'est un peu le cas du
pakistan et le pakistan simultanément et
kabok d'aider les talibans juste à côté
parce que vis-à-vis de ce rapport avec
l'asnl organisme constitue le commandeur
l'arrière fond stratégique donc ils ont
eu une politique afghane pratiquement
depuis 79 ils ont alimenté toutes les
formes de violence en afghanistan depuis
l'invasion soviétique et ça c'est
toujours poursuivi est donc bien
évidemment le pakistan et la zone si
vous voulez le soutien principal de la
chose il reste l'autre part que beaucoup
des talibans s'ils voulaient ont été
formés dans des écoles coraniques qui
avait été ouvert par l'arabie saoudite à
l'époque de l'occupation soviétique avec
le soutien des occidentaux et donc les
talibans sont aussi un produit de
l'arabie saoudite et des stupidités du
soutien occidental si vous voulez à la
lutte antisoviétique donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui piégé par une force on a
aidé à constituer
premier jour de deuil national en
algérie où les efforts se poursuivent
pour venir à bout des incendies qui
ravagent la kabylie depuis lundi ils ont
fait 69 morts dont 28 militaires qui y
luttaient contre les flammes des départs
de feux favorisés par la canicule mais
dont l'origine pourrait être aussi être
criminel antoine ogier
un sentiment de désolation face à un
paysage dévasté par les flammes
un grand incendie s'est déclaré on ne
peut pas y échapper quelques personnes
et moi avons fermé la route pour
qu'aucune voiture ne passe en 20 minutes
il ne restait plus rien de ce village
toute la population a été évacuée vers
la mosquée avec les femmes et les
enfants et le reste des habitants
étaient piégés ici certains ont commencé
à pleurer d'autres à crier a supplié
comme si c'était la fin du monde
quelque chose que vous voyez ici en
kabylie ces derniers jours tout est
éteint l'incendié
comme
on habite juste à côté de notre europe
de faire quelque chose que de ne pas
rester les bras croisés comme c'est de
nos traditions nos traditions toujours
de se prendre en charge soit même ici au
cap et les incendies déclarés dans la
soirée de lundi en kabylie qui n'ont
laissé aucune chance aux animaux prises
au piège ont fait partir en cendres des
hectares de forêts et des centaines
d'habitations
mardi quatre personnes suspectées de
pyromanie ont été arrêtés l'une d'entre
elles est rapidement passé aux aveux
pour le gouvernement il fait peu de
doute sur l'origine criminelle des
incendies
tout comme des témoins chez qui
l'incompréhension demeure
nous avons vu le seul le matin de loin
et en deux minutes il est arrivé ici
c'est incroyable nous ne pouvons pas du
tout nous comprendre heureusement il y
avait des gens qui ont évacué nos
familles et les personnes âgées mercredi
au centre ville dénis terre-à-terre et
nous nous battons et essayons autant que
possible d'intervenir pour éteindre le
feu pour protéger nos maisons vraiment
nous ne comprenons pas comment cela a pu
arriver au temps de feu en un jour ce
n'est pas normal
une situation catastrophique largement
favorisé par les conditions
météorologiques auxquels fait face le
pays avec des chaleurs allant jusqu'à 47
degrés dans certaines régions et de
faibles précipitations
à cause du climat actuel en afrique du
nord la puissance dé feu sort de
l'ordinaire cela oblige à envoyer
beaucoup de monde parfois à pied dans
des conditions qui sont dangereuses avec
ces températures c'est extrêmement
difficile de travailler pour les forces
armées
le nord de l'algérie toujours en proie
aux flammes reçoit dès ce jeudi le
soutien de canadair français et
marocains le président algérien a quant
à lui décrété un deuil national de trois
jours en hommage aux civils et
militaires décédés depuis mardi soir et
le peu de moyens déployés par les
autorités algériennes en kabylie région
habituellement aussi le pouvoir central
alimentent la colère des habitants
les précisions maghreb de notre
correspondant bassam celle des algériens
en colère une opposition qui n'a pas
hésité à monter au créneau ces derniers
jours l'algérie est en proie à
d'importants feux de forêt est déclarée
dans le nord du pays en haute kabylie
les wilayas de tizi ouzou et béjaïa
pleurent leurs morts parmi l'élite il
des militaires et des civils alors que
des foyers demeurent toujours
incontrôlables face à la situation
beaucoup d'habitants déplorent le manque
de réactivité du gouvernement écouter
les soldats et les membres de la garde
nationale se sont rendus sur le terrain
pour aider est un incendie mais les
fonctionnaires haut placés n'ont vu
aucun d'entre eux et ils ne les ont pas
cherché je n'ai de problème avec
personne mais vous voyez de vos propres
yeux des crimes contre l'humanité c'est
vraiment une catastrophe plus tôt la
pire des catastrophes
quelques a échoué tout comme les civils
l'opposition elle aussi est monté au
créneau c'est le cas du rassemblement
pour la culture et la démocratie qui
s'en est violemment pris aux goûts
ernement dans un communiqué rendu public
hier leur chef de file mohcine belabbas
a déploré un manque flagrant de moyens
de lutte contre les feux de forêt
appelant les autorités à se doter d'un
nombre important de canadair elle la
totale absence de réactivité et
d'anticipation une communication des
plus archaïques sont caractéristiques de
la gestion de cette présente crise qui
dure à l'ère des télécommunications de
pointe et des technologies ultramodernes
de l'information et de la communication
le chef de l'état est incapable de
s'adresser au peuple par l'image et le
son dans ces moments de désarroi de
deuil et de tristesse
le reste du gouvernement n'est pas en
reste de leur côté le ministre de
l'intérieur et le premier ministre ont
affirmé hier que les incendies qui ont
touché la wilaya de tizi ouzou sont
d'origine criminelle
évoquant un acte prémédité pour faire le
plus de dégâts
l'état comme vous pouvez le constater
déploie tous ses efforts et nous avons
utilisé toutes les possibilités et les
équipements publics pour accueillir les
citoyens qui ont été touchés par cette
catastrophe nous avons donné des
instructions strictes aux gouverneurs
des régions pour qu'ils ordonnent à tous
les logements universitaires
actuellement disponibles et à tous les
hôtels même privé d'accueillir tous les
citoyennes qui ont été touchés par ces
incendies et de leur fournir tous les
moyens nécessaires pour un logement
décent de la meilleure façon jusqu'à ce
que cette catastrophe parce si dieu le
veut
un gouvernement visé par la grogne
populaire déjà dépassés par la situation
sanitaire avec une explosion des cas
depuis début juillet et un manque de
moyens pour y faire face le pouvoir à
alger est à nouveau la cible des réseaux
sociaux qui y dénoncent les défaillances
de l'état
élection présidentielle en zambie le
scrutin s'annonce serré entre le
président sortant et de gares loubouer
son traditionnel rival à candé ici les
mâts dans un contexte tendu entre grave
crise économique et déploiement de
l'armée pour contenir les violences de
ces dernières semaines les précisions
avec grace d'aia et amaya saouler
ils sont sept millions d'électeurs à
être appelés aux urnes ce jeudi dans ce
pays d'afrique australe riche en cuivre
mais fortement endetté seize candidats
en tout mais une bataille rangée se joue
entre deux rivaux de toujours le
président sortant edgar logo 64 ans et a
kind et ishi l'ema 59 ans ce dernier un
solide homme d'affaires autodidacte né
dans une famille modeste total outsider
en politique s'est hissé à la tête du
parti d'opposition upn des à la mort de
son ancien leader en 2006
c'est la sixième fois qu'il se présente
et cette fois il compte bien l'emporter
et remettre le pays sur pied
notre pays à l'occasion de redresser
cette situation que nos occasions rares
pourrait dire de redresser cette
situation et permettons un changement de
gouvernement harmonieux nous n'avons pas
besoin de détruire le pays pour rester
au pouvoir to destroy déclenchées
de l'autre côté le président sortant est
garni goût avocat de formation au
pouvoir depuis 2000 15 à développer une
répression à l'égard de tous ses
opposants faisant fermer plusieurs
médias indépendants et même emprisonné
son opposant quatre mois après sa
contestation des résultats de la
présidentielle en 2016 où il l'avait
battu de justesse
cette fois ci il ne se doute pas de sa
victoire il joue la carte de
l'apaisement face aux nombreuses
critiques dont il est la cible
je tiens à souligner que le peuple a
parlé qu'il n'y ait pas de représailles
du côté des vainqueurs ni de colère et
de désenchantement du côté des perdants
ce qui plongerait le pays dans le chaos
ce n'est pas nécessaire
la semaine dernière des violences ont
éclaté entre militants du front
patriotique au pouvoir et du parti uni
pour le développement national de a kind
et ishi l'ema poussant le président a
déployé l'armée une décision dénoncée
par l'opposition qui y voit une forme
d'intimidation le problème auquel nous
sommes confrontés en ce moment est un
problème de mauvais leadership
c'est un problème de mauvaise
gouvernance et si les gens sont
intimidés et ray chez eux sans voter
alors nous ne changerons pas le statu
quo par conséquent nous devons braver
les intimidations nous devons braver la
violence est allé voter en nombre afin
de changer la situation actuelle des
karens et
l'emploi fortement touché une inflation
qui a grimpé à plus de 20% une crise
économique accentués par la crise
sanitaire la zambie devient le premier
pays d'afrique à se retrouver en défaut
de paiement depuis l'apparition du coc
vie de 19
et on en vient la situation sanitaire où
le nombre de cas positifs au commis 19
aux états unis est en nette augmentation
selon les dernières données des
autorités sanitaires sont treize mille
cas un nouveau ont été enregistrés en
moyenne ces derniers jours face à cette
vague épidémique de plus en plus d'état
et d'entreprises ont décidé d'imposer la
vaccination aux salariés et pour en
parler on va tout de suite rejoindre
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnin
thomas bonsoir alors comment sont perçus
ces nouvelles mesures aux états unis
et bien le fait que la vaccination
obligatoire gagne du terrain aux
etats-unis c'est un fait qui a été salué
ce jeudi par les autorités sanitaires
américaines qui ont tenu un point presse
elle se félicite que de plus en plus
d'employés fédéraux des universités et
d'entreprises privées aient décidé
d'imposer la vaccination à leurs
salariés ou à leurs étudiants et il ya
même des états qui souhaitent montrer
l'exemple on a là encore un peu plus
loin c'est le cas par exemple de l'état
de californie où le gouverneur a annoncé
de nouvelles mesures je propose
d'écouter
l'état de californie toujours dans
l'idée de montrer l'exemple a également
affirmé que nous devions faire plus et
faire mieux en devenant le premier état
du pays a exigé un passeport vaccinale
ou au moins d'exiger un test pcr
nous adaptons donc notre stratégie
aujourd'hui pour l'aligner sur celle de
l'état et ainsi devenir le premier état
du pays a exigé que tout notre personnel
pas seulement les enseignants le
personnel a crédité les paras éducateurs
le personnel d'entretien et chauffeurs
de bus les gens qui sont essentiels pour
se tenir l'ensemble de l'écosystème
scolaire se mettent également à une
vérification de la vaccination et où se
soumettent à des tests hebdomadaires
alors il faut noter que le plus grand
syndicat de professeurs aux états unis a
salué cette mesure et s'est prononcé
donc en faveur de la vaccination
obligatoire pour les professeurs sur
l'ensemble du territoire américain pour
le moment il n'y a pas de mesures au
niveau fédéral de la part du
gouvernement américain la liberté est
donnée aux différentes localités
d'ailleurs les autorités sanitaires lors
de ce point presse ce jeudi ont expliqué
qu'il n'y aurait pas non plus de bases
de données au niveau fédéral des preuves
de vaccination pas de qr codes à la
française donc pour le moment ici et
libertés est donc donné aux états
notamment de décider d'apposer ou non de
nouvelles mesures et on assiste en
réalité à une bataille entre les états
démocrates et les états républicains il
ya notamment deux états républicains qui
sont dans le viseur des autorités
sanitaires et plus généralement du
gouvernement américain il s'agit de du
texas et de la floride puisque les
autorités sanitaires américaines lors de
ce point presse ont affirmé que 40 % des
hospitalisations dans le pays en ce
moment sont concentrées justement dans
ces deux états deux états ou les deux
gouverneurs républicains sont opposés
aux mesures de restriction par exemple
dans le texas le gouverneur a annoncé
qu'il allait lancer des poursuites
contre tous ceux qui décideraient
d'imposer le port du masque à
l'intérieur de l'état et puis en floride
le gouverneur a lui annoncé qu'il
pourrait y avoir des retenues sur
salaire pour les dirigeants des
établissements scolaires qui là encore
souhaiterait imposer le port du masque
le gouverneur de floride run de santis
préfère que ce soit aux parents de
décider s'ils veulent ou non faire
porter le masque à leur enfant assiste
donc à un bras de fer entre ses élus
républicains et le président joe biden
on a même assisté à une passe d'armes
entre le gouverneur de floride run de
santis et joe biden ces derniers jours
par médias interposés une fracture
politique autour du commis 19 qui n'est
finalement pas nouvelle parce qu'il faut
se rappeler que l'an passé déjà lorsque
donald trump était président des états
unis il y avait eu quelques débats faut
se souvenir notamment que des démocrates
dont joe biden et kamala harris lors de
la dernière campagne présidentielle
s'était montré plutôt sceptiques quant à
la capacité de donald trump de preuves
de proposer un vaccin à la population
américaine
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnaire en direct
depuis washington
et c'est un record depuis le début de la
pandémie la russie vient d'enregistrer
808 mort 24 heures près de 22000
nouvelles contaminations aux colis donc
également été recensés
les précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou vers amos man
808 mort la russie renouvelle son triste
record de mortalité depuis août les
chiffres et et aux alentours de 790
décès quotidiens les virologues russe
explique ce pic de décès par la
propagation du variant delta le non
respect des gestes-barrières ainsi que
le faible nombre des personnes vaccinées
la russie en compte seulement 39
millions sur 146 millions écouter
personne ne porte de masque personnes ne
respectent les distances ni les mesures
de protection ne se désinfecter les
mains rien il s'agit d'une violation de
toutes les règles sanitaires et
épidémiologiques
énormément de gens ne sont pas vaccinés
un nouveau variant est apparu il se
propage rapidement plus vite dans les
contacts ce sont des choses indépendante
pour se protéger soi même et ses proches
il faut se faire vacciner si les gens ne
se font pas vacciner ne respectent pas
les mesures de confinement de quoi
parle-t-on quand auto décontamination
des hospitalisations tous les deux sont
en baisse ces tendances peut être
observé non seulement à moscou mais
aussi dans d'autres régions russes
écoutez nous constatons une diminution
du nombre de nouveaux cas d'infection
une diminution du nombre de patients
hospitalisés dans différentes régions
la baisse du taux est à peu près la même
c'est peut-être simplement étiré dans le
temps le système de santé acquis de
l'expérience au cours de ces 18 mois
cela nous permet de dire que nous
n'avons pas peur que nous n'avons aucune
crainte face un scénario négatif qui
pourraient potentiellement se dérouler
en septembre près de vingt deux mille
nouveaux cas de couronner virus ont été
détectés en russie ces dernières 24
heures dont près de 2300 à moscou depuis
le début de la pandémie 6,5 millions de
russes ont contracté le qu'ovide le
nombre de décès s'élève désormais à plus
de 168 milles personnes
en france la situation sanitaire aux
antilles inquiète les ministres de la
santé et des outre-mer sont en
martinique pour évaluer la situation
alors que l'île est confiné confinement
qui va se durcir également guadeloupe
les indicateurs en effet son vol le
d'incidence et de 1900 malade pour
100000 habitants 25 % de taux de
possibles de positivité aux tests selon
sébastien lecornu lé ministre des autres
maires et des renforts ont été envoyés à
partir de demain et pour au moins trois
semaines fermeture des commerces donnée
essentielle marc restaurant et plages
couvre feu étendu et sortie limitée à
moins de 5 km de domicile de nouvelles
mesures pour casser la chaîne des
contaminations le préfet de guadeloupe
appelle à limiter les interactions
sociales écouter la seule consigne que
je peux donner c'est qu'à partir de
maintenant il faut que chacun reste chez
soi à son domicile sauf s'il a des
activités indispensables à effectuer je
reviendrai dessus mais c'est vraiment la
consigne majeur qui doit être qui doit
être respecté on est trois semaines qui
viennent il faut absolument que nous
évitions les interactions sociales sauf
celles qui sont indispensables et puis
pour les touristes qui sont présents en
guadeloupe qu'il en reste encore
quelques-uns ne souhaite pas qu'il
quitte la guadeloupe immédiatement mais
simplement évidemment là à la fin de
leur séjour ils seront ils rentreront
par leur vol ils peuvent aussi en lien
avec avec les hôtels et avec les
compagnies aériennes pour voir des
départs plus anticipé en fonction en
fonction des places dans les avions bien
entendu et en métropole l'état des lieux
est également préoccupant selon emmanuel
macron de nouvelles mesures ont été
annoncées hier pour éviter la fermeture
du pays selon le chef de l'état masque
obligatoire en intérieur dans les zones
à forte incidence pour inciter à la
vaccination les tests pcr ne seront plus
remboursés à partir de mi octobre et une
campagne de rappel pour une troisième
dose sera mis en place mi septembre à
destination des plus vulnérables le
passager terre et lui étendu aux grands
centres commerciaux situés dans des
départements où le taux d'incidence
dépasse les 200 pour cent mille
l'entreprise des livres ou suspend ses
activités de livraison à domicile en
espagne en cause une loi votée en mai
dernier par le gouvernement espagnol
elle oblige les entreprises à salarier
les livreurs mais l'entreprise
britannique refuse de se conformer à
cette loi les précisions de leslie
singles à
3870 personnes vont se retrouver sans
emploi suite au départ de des libéraux
le groupe britannique a fait le choix
d'arrêter ses activités en espagne suite
à la loi ryder la loi impose aux
sociétés faisant des livraisons à
domicile via des applications numériques
d'embaucher comme salariés tous leurs
livreurs jusqu'à présent les livreurs
travailler avec le statut d'auto
entrepreneur le texte juridique qui
entre en vigueur en ce mois d'août en
espagne le rassure donc une plus grande
protection allocations chômage congés
payés salaire minimum ou arrêt maladie
mais les livreurs se retrouveront sans
emploi à l'automne l'entreprise a
expliqué que l'espagne représente une
petite part de son marché mondial et
faire partie des leaders représenterait
un investissement trop élevé et une
rentabilité incertaine à long terme des
libéraux préfèrent donc se recentrer sur
d'autres pays les syndicats des
travailleurs en espagne sont indignés je
vous propose d'écouter le responsable de
l'association des livreurs à barcelone
en tant qu'association nous avons alerté
le ministère du travail et les
organismes sociaux que sont les
syndicats cgt et force ouvrière de la
tragédie et l'impact social que peuvent
causer le départ d'une entreprise aussi
grande que des livres ou qui est cotée
en bourse comme le gouvernement n'a pu
trouver aucun accord avec l'entreprise
des libéraux a décidé de quitter le pays
or une telle décision a un impact sur
plus de 3000 employés en espagne nous
aimerions entreprendre des négociations
dans lesquelles se déciderait le futur
de l'entreprise et le futur des
travailleurs au sujet des indemnités de
licenciements et du chômage
de leur côté les entreprises
concurrentes comme globaux au just hits
resteront présentes en espagne elles ont
eu trois mois pour s'adapter à cette
nouvelle loi près de 30000 livreur au
père pour ces géants du numérique en
espagne mais c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes rester avec nous
sur rt france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe islamisme radical de
la saur c'est l'élite des renseignements
généraux de la police française et
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service vous ne pouvez absolument pas
refusé votre mission première est celle
de traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que moi c'est fini pour moi est
ce que ça remet en armes tout est passé
dans ma tête est ce que vous avez appris
de ces profils qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
chercher d'ailleurs dans la religion le
profil vient toujours de la misère
sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation il faut que
nous reprenions la place dans le cerveau
des enfants et de la jeunesse
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe nous sommes chez vox harry